president joe biden wants every state
across the country to make the
coronavirus vaccine available to
everyone by april 19th just a couple of
weeks from now
nevada already allows anyone 16 and
older to get the medicine
even with higher vaccination rates covet
19 cases are still picking up as
restrictions are relaxed
health officials say the uk variant of
covid19 is now the most prevalent here
in the u.s
as the world starts to travel again the
biden administration says it's not
going to mandate a vaccine passport but
it's not going to stop businesses or
universities from taking action
they're going to say we're not going to
have you come in unless you get
vaccinated
dr anthony fauci there at least eight
colleges have already
said they will require vaccinations for
students before they go back to campus
in the fall
in the uk a pediatric trial for the
astrazeneca coronavirus vaccine is
stalled
university of oxford doctors say they
have some concerns about a rare blood
clotting issue in some adults who
received that
shot the trial is not going to resume
until those concerns are resolved
europe's drug regulator says the
benefits of the vaccine though still
outweigh any potential risks
astrazeneca's vaccine has not been
approved here in the u.s